okay so here is hhs secretary health and
human service
secretary alex azar he is seated he is
about to receive
his first dose howie it's certainly a
moment just like the vice president who
received his the other day they show up
in their short sleeve shirt so there's
easy access to the arm there
but he will be receiving his vaccine as
many lawmakers are first in line for
this the elderly obviously
front and line are our front line health
care workers across the country
there are waiting lists as you well know
as we see the the secretary about to
receive his shot
uh for people signing up to get this as
soon as possible around the country
yeah this is a nice christmas gift for
the country and particularly those who
can get it early on i have to remind
everybody that six months ago i went
back and reviewed the coverage
almost all the media almost all the
experts said there was no way that
president trump could deliver on his
pledge
to have a vaccine roll out by the end of
the year well they were wrong
he was right i haven't seen many people
crediting the president's leadership on
operation warp speed
obviously these companies pfizer modern
all the scientists who work long hours
deserve a lot of credit as well and of
course there's going to be some
jockeying sandra
as we watch these pictures but at least
we are now
on the road to getting more of the
country vaccinated it's frustrating that
it will take a few more months obviously
all right so he's got his first shot now
we await 80 year old dr fauci he'll be
next in line we all watched vice
president mike pence get his
in the last several days or at least the
first shot along with the second lady
karen pence dr faucino
is approaching the medical worker who
will be administering his shot
doctors have recommended president trump
hold off on his shot for now because of
the experimental treatment that he
received when of course he was in the
hospital
here's dr fauci let's stop and listen
and take this information
is that i'm an attending physician here
on the staff
at the national institutes of health
clinical center and so i do see patients
but
as important or more important is as a
symbol
to the rest of the country that i feel
extreme confidence
in the safety and the efficacy of this
vaccine and i want to encourage
everyone who has the opportunity to get
vaccinated so that we could have a veil
of protection over this country
that would end this pandemic
thank you dr fauci for coming today
any last minute questions concerns no
all right i'm gonna just scrunch up a
little bit
should i get a good intramuscular
injection here
thanks for helping out
and before you let go
[Applause]
and two thumbs up from dr fauci saying
he's got extreme confidence in this
vaccine he was just given the modern a
vaccine it received
emergency approval howie just this past
week last friday began shipping over the
weekend we
of course began to see the site of all
of those vaccines getting delivered
operation warp speed plans to distribute
5.9
million doses across the country this
week howie your reaction to what you
just saw
look anthony fauci's comments are
precisely why he should not only get the
vaccine in addition to the fact that
he's 80
years old but do it on live television
he can send a message i know he's been
at odds with the president and everybody
thinks he hasn't had a perfect record on
this but he is sending a message to all
of america this is safe
i'm taking it you can take it when it
becomes available i think it was an
important
television moment i'm glad that we're
covering it uh because symbolism is
important here and dr fauci
a lot of people respect his views
because he's done this in republican and
democratic administrations alike and he
also made news earlier today saying that
he believes that this new strain that
we're all
fearing and reading about he he believes
that these vaccines will also be
effective
with that all right